[Music]
hey
everybody and we are here and we hit 10
000 subscribers
i joke he just noticed and i just
noticed because i haven't been on
youtube all day mostly because i've been
working on some other [ __ ] on my other
computer
i noticed it and then uh a badger
noticed it in the
comments but uh that means we're a
bronze channel now back in
back in the good old days of youtube
they would have sent us a bronze plaque
but they don't do that anymore
i don't need a brian i don't have
anywhere to put a bronze black honestly
i'd probably buy one where the [ __ ] am i
gonna put that right
i'll make my own if i want that
yeah i know it's like now it's it's
feels so weird because we've been it
seemed like it took so long like
it's all youtubey in here now it's all
youtubey
yeah it's all youtube like it's a real
channel
god we wouldn't want that to happen yeah
i i like our kind of cantankerous sort
of like
patched together sort of show they still
complain though
every day yeah but like people are going
to complain about i you know what i
think some people are only happy if
they're complaining about something
i mean the big shows we do the big shows
half that show we're pretty [ __ ]
trashed
we get through it real well hey i like i
like some shows like that have you seen
like the guys from red letter media that
do
uh what the [ __ ] is the name of that
show half in the bag
and they usually do like two movie
reviews like new movies and they usually
get like drunker and drucker like as it
goes on
and same with beer and board games they
usually usually it's funnier
like the drunker they get like the
longer the show goes on because they're
all like yelling at each other
yeah and there's four or five of them so
there's more people to play off of yeah
it's hard as just two people especially
when they've just lived together for a
[ __ ] decade
a lot of funny [ __ ] it's already we
already said you said that [ __ ] long
time ago
yeah we have to keep coming up with new
[ __ ] all the time yeah because otherwise
like yeah i heard it yeah sometimes i
pull a good one out though you sometimes
you start [ __ ] busting up and [ __ ]
you said well you still got there's
there's still some good fun when i say
some crazy [ __ ]
yeah that's sure yeah manko says that's
all part of the fun of the channel we
all get trash that's what i mean we're
all getting trashed together
yeah yeah trying to [ __ ] prevent
prevent yourself from becoming an alky
yeah yeah
it would have happened already yeah i
kind of feel like i mean we drink a lot
but it's not like
we would have been alcoholics already
it's not like i'm in here in the day
like being like man i need a drink man i
do i don't think about it until like
and i don't even think about it every
evening it's like but usually if i'm
gonna like you know sit back and watch a
horror movie or something
then yeah i'll have we really only get
trashed once a week pretty much
on the show yeah i mean because
sometimes like in
in the evening sometimes we'll have like
a drink yeah like while we're watching a
movie or something but usually
like that well like i had a drink last
night
yeah but yeah i didn't get drunk no i
just had one and then like i just had
some water and then i went to sleep
because we were watching this movie yeah
uh
no actually we weren't i was actually
reading last night we watched this movie
sunday night because what happened was
we were actually supposed to go
to memento mori last night yeah and then
that's a good thing we did yeah i was
well what happened was i ended up
getting like this
super super rush like graphic design job
which i really i'm almost done with that
i have like one more page like this
eight page newsletter or something so
it's like i still have one more page to
do on that because i told her i'd have
it done by like first thing tomorrow
morning
so i really had to do that and the dudes
came and pressure washed the house this
morning
like early and i was like yeah they're
going to be waking us up at the ass
crack at dawn and i don't want to have
to be hungover and be like hey dudes i
don't even want fresh washing the house
okay
and like you know what i mean so and i
was just like so sleepy because i woke
up at 5 00 a.m and i was like you know
what i
it kind of sucks we can't go below taco
and now i'm kind of glad that we didn't
because
i had so much [ __ ] work today and i
just didn't want to be
hungover all day the pressure washers
came i had to
supervise make sure they pressure wash
the damn driveway
oh yeah yeah because they're supposed to
do this yeah have you no i
was good no i've been like really good i
have had my face in that super laptop
like doing the [ __ ]
[ __ ] over there yeah it does look good
yeah it's been it's been
several several years i think it's been
like six or seven years since we had a
pressure wash last
time yeah i'm housing the housing
commissions games told me to do it
yeah they'll whine if you don't we have
the house yeah we have the hoa
yeah and it just had a little bit of
moss growing if you don't cut your grass
or wash your
they're not as bad as they used to be
because i think they have like some new
management in there now
and we know them like or you know them
yeah so it's like they're not like to
no you know btk about
yeah so let's talk about this [ __ ] here
it looks like everybody's here let's
talk about
this movie this is a movie that i had
this came out in 2019
it's called depraved um i didn't hear a
great deal about it
but uh i saw it come up on hulu all i
knew about it was that it was written
directed edited etc by larry fessenden
which
i you know he's like a cool dude i'll
talk a little bit about him in a minute
and that it was kind of like a modern
updating of the frankenstein story
which i was like well that sounds pretty
cool you know what i mean i like
frankenstein's story as much as the next
person i know a lot of them
uh you know don't come out all that well
but um
so i thought i would give this one a
spin hold on one second what's that
people in the comments see this is uh
roy from england he said congratulations
from england
still listening to your old stuff so
funny
i watched blacula last night after you
reviewed brilliant
yeah you should see the sequel to that
too you should see scream black of the
screen
i might like scream black you'll scream
slightly better than the first one
although they're both excellent yeah
they're both real good but the second
one's even better i like the second one
a little bit better because i think
because it has all that voodoo [ __ ]
going
on and i love food yeah they bring black
black yellow back from the dead
yeah yeah a voodoo priest does it yeah
yeah it's pretty good yeah it's awesome
then he turns them into vampires the
thing is though is that
it's still the shortcut there was a long
cut of that that was a bunch of stuff
that was cut out
that inspired anne rice to do about uh
to to
it inspired her a lot about the vampire
chronicles you know what i mean about
how you
turn a person into a vampire and make
him your slave just so you could have
his house
that's what he does to that black dude
yeah because i'm a slave he goes yes
they cut that [ __ ] out i guess they
didn't like the slavery references in it
or something you know
but uh i saw the long played version and
[ __ ] mama walde
enslaved black people and turned them
into vampires
and that they cut that part out well he
does it it's just that he said he was
doing it
and yeah that part out that dude is like
so [ __ ] epic in that yeah
one of my favorite vampire portrayals in
any movie
he's got the best [ __ ] voice he was
on star trek too obviously
um but yeah so uh louis said i forgot
what show tom and jenny were really
smashed the show went off the rails
toward the end i think that was the
collar bomb show
yeah remember the one that we talked
about the collar bomb cases we were
pretty smashed in the last one i walked
off the show at the very end i said [ __ ]
i'm about somebody i'm gonna go make
taco you wouldn't now you come back
he fluffed at me she goes back to go get
me
you're not coming back to the show and i
was like i'm eating
he says all right i'll come back i came
back to show you eating and shut it down
that was just the last one we did yeah
it was
somebody said we're functional
alcoholics not really well maybe like i
said but i i always kind of feel like
because i knew someone that was an
alcoholic i'm not going to say if it was
but
yeah there's a big difference a friend
of mine was actually and yeah and
i mean this person would like couldn't
go anywhere without carrying booze
around like in their purse
you know what i mean the acid test is if
you get the shakes
yeah but if you're not you know if it's
a real functional alcoholic if they go a
couple days without alcohol they start
shaking
yes we don't do that no like i said i
sometimes i just like to have a drink it
in the evening if i'm watching a movie i
don't really like to get super smashed
anymore because i know i'll feel like
crap the next day
yeah so i try but on the show sometimes
we're having a good time and
i'd lose track so you know but what are
you gonna do yeah
so uh so yeah this movie so like i said
larry fessenden if you don't know
he is actually a writer director
producer he writes horror games he
writes horror movies
um he helps out like a lot of other
indie horror filmmakers he's also a
character actor he's been in a [ __ ] ton
of like horror movies
and so he just seems like an all-around
cool horror dude like somebody that's
like kind of a
mover in the shaker or whatever in the
[ __ ] indie horror community
and this i think is his first movie that
he's like directed
for six years because i think he's been
like helping other uh directors out with
their projects
but this is the first one he's done so
this is basically like i said it's sort
of like an
updating of the frankenstein story
i want to call it i maybe want to call
it hipster frankenstein but that seems
like a little glib
i'm just saying it's because it's
basically there's this guy named henry
and he was a combat medic and he has
uh ptsd because of all the people he
couldn't save or whatever and so he
him and his friend uh john polidori
that you know if you don't know who that
is the guy that wrote the vampire from
back in the day
and um you know he was uh lord byron's
physician
at the haunted summer all of that so him
and his friend polidori
uh who is the the financier he's like
kind of the brains and also kind of the
money behind the operation
so polidori has invented this drug
uh i think it's called rad x or rap x or
something like that
and then henry is like this genius
surgeon so the two of them
are conspiring they have this big like
abandoned
warehouse lab that's like i think it's
in brooklyn somewhere
and they're basically like finding
bodies
and stitching them together and doing
the whole like frankenstein monster
thing so when this movie starts you get
like a few minutes with this
couple who have just moved in together
they're kind of having a little bit of
an argument
about um fatherhood i guess she wants to
have kids and he does not ready yet and
blah blah blah so they're
like having a fight about that and so
he's gonna go back to
his apartment and while he's on his way
back to his apartment he gets set upon
by
an unknown assailant in the street and
is stabbed
to death and uh after that he gets
dragged back to
this warehouse of horrors where he
i don't think like because the guy that
plays the the monster
is not the same dude from the beginning
so i think only that dude's brain
was yet because that later on they show
like you know i'm getting stitched
together from like a whole bunch of
different parts
because that guy's like a lot taller
than the first guy but i think that it
that his brain like gets popped into
this monster
so when the monster wakes up henry's
like super excited because this is i
guess
presumably he's done like a bunch of
experiments before and they have failed
so this is like the first dude that's
actually woken up and like started
walking around and [ __ ]
so then like for the first like the
first act of the movie is basically
henry being like super jazzed about
you know bringing essentially this
person back from the dead
and sort of trying to teach him to be
human again he teaches them to talk he
teaches them to read he teaches them
like you know
all that other kind of stuff and um just
as in frankenstein
uh the novel things go wildly off the
rails
one thing that i did like about this
movie was that
unlike a lot of frankenstein adaptations
this one it's still a horror movie but
it concentrates more on
the kind of philosophical um
kind of stuff there a lot of which was
actually in the novel
so it kind of went a lot more in that
direction which i thought was really
interesting because you don't really see
a lot of adaptations that do that sort
of thing
it's very very shallow it is oh yeah
big time was it a great horror movie i
didn't think so
i don't even know if i would call it a
horrible it's it has
it has horror aspects it has sci-fi
aspects
a lot of it was kind of like it was
almost like more
psychological horror because a lot of
the um the horror came from
um you feeling bad for
this kid at the beginning i think his
name was alex
this guy who just got stabbed walking
down the street like for no [ __ ]
reason
and then his brain gets popped into this
monster and he sort of remembers stuff
like he sort of remembers his girlfriend
and he like kind of remembers things
but not entirely so as he just like
keeps learning things
and then like the the kind of triangle
that develops between him
and henry and polidori because henry and
polidori have like
different um you know ways that they
want to approach
essentially parenting this monster that
they've made
i mean because polydory is just like i'm
going to take him out of the town he
gives him cocaine he takes him to a
strip club he does like all this other
kind of stuff he's like live your life
man you know what i mean
so it's almost kind of like the two part
like business partners are having like
these kind of squabbles about
that they're not bringing up the monster
correctly yeah
um so that's kind of like seems like the
main conflict of the movie
but i did like that they actually went a
lot into
so i think it's like less a horror movie
it's just it's really sad like i found
it like really sad because you find
you're like you feel really bad for adam
like the monster
because you know he didn't like have any
choice about this he doesn't and he
still kind of remembers [ __ ] and he kind
of remembers that
you know this isn't right and he doesn't
know how to like
be a person really yeah you know
universal frank no no it's nothing like
the movie
it kind of reminds me it's more like the
novel really it kind of reminds me of
remember
remember it reminded me a little bit
more of the frankenstein that had uh
robert de niro playing frankenstein in
it a little bit although that
movie was not great it wasn't that good
but this one was actually more
i would say this one's more like a
little bit on the fun side almost
in a way it wasn't a bad movie but yeah
it kind of had it was kind of good
harder in certain parts of it you know
what i mean
i mean weird [ __ ] happened but
you just got to see it for yourself you
got to judge it you got to judge it yeah
i mean i really didn't be in the mood
for it i think that
yeah and keep in mind it's it's long for
a horror movie i think it's it's almost
two hours long
it's an hour 54 minutes or something
like that which is a little long for a
horror movie
um and like i said it's not you know
don't expect something like the
universal monster movies or like you
know wherever this is alive don't expect
anything like that and that those are
cool i like those movies
but this is much more like a
philosophical treatise like much more
like the novel
is um what is consciousness what is
consciousness what makes you you
yeah and like and you know it kind of
like uh comes at those kind of bigger
questions about
you know the implications also what's
good what's good and what's evil
yeah of like [ __ ] that would happen like
if you actually did this
like actually like sewed a person
together and popped somebody's brain in
there and like brought them back to life
you know what is your responsibility
toward this
creature what is this that's what the
original was more which is more like
what the original one was
so this is actually even though it's
modern and it's updated it's set in
brooklyn
um and there's obviously a lot of you
know modern flourishes
and it's much more grounded in realism
shelley got all this when she you know
she was a kid
basically when she wrote this yeah she
was 18 i think yeah she was having a
competition it's amazing she's having a
competition with her brother with her
husband and somebody else
lord byron yeah and john paul adore you
yeah who could write
who could write the best horror story
the best ghost story yeah and she wrote
this one and
what inspired her was uh down in the
universities they were taking
dead people and shocking them yeah dead
bodies and shocking them and they would
move
yeah they were trying to figure out the
nervous system so galvanism
galvanism yeah so um
you know people were wondering whether
or not they could maybe accidentally
bring somebody back to life by doing
that
you know no you can't
but back in the 1700s well they didn't
know he didn't know
i mean it seemed like was that late
1700s or i think it was late 1700s you
were there
no eighteen hundred eighteen and late
yeah what year of the eighteen hundreds
because well she came up with the idea
in 1816. okay because that was the
that was the haunted summer i didn't
wanna do a show about that i did a
board game based on it because it's an
old story
yeah it's a very old story but weirdly
modern kind of like the first sci-fi
story but i think that people that have
you know because the frankenstein story
is like so ingrained in popular culture
mostly because of the universal movies
and all the subsequent adaptations i
think people
when they read the novel because we read
the book in high school
um when you read the novel people are
surprised at how like philosophical it
is
yeah you know what i mean and it goes a
lot into
you know how much responsibility does
the doctor have like for creating that
and
in a way they kind of like hammered that
a lot in this movie
where essentially the two guys who
created this person the guy that made
the drug and
gave the funding and the surgeon that
actually stitched it all together
um the two of them were like surrogate
parents to this monster and like they
had like wildly different ideas about
how he should be
you know brought into society um because
they've just mostly wanted to make money
off the [ __ ]
you know i mean like off the drug and
off the technique or whatever
so they were trying to like essentially
groom him
for like a public presentation like look
what we did you know what i mean
so they go a lot into that kind of uh
thing too so like i said don't go into
it expecting it to be
a horror movie per se it does have
horror elements to it
there is some gore which i think is all
practical effects i
was a big fan i know some other
reviewers don't like it but
i was actually kind of a fan of like all
the cool um
the weird like neon visual stuff they
did like out so there
where they were kind of like showing you
know thought process and it's like
synapses and stuff like that i thought
that was kind of cool like
they did that like quite a lot as a
motif like during the movie and i
thought that was kind of neat
but um zach mentioned that this she did
it for around
1815 because that volcano erupted yeah
it was 1816 was the year without a
summer
because that volcano erupted and then
like it not um
you know it yeah it knocked out the wind
really [ __ ] up the weather like
everything got cold like they didn't
like all the [ __ ] crops died and all
this other kind of [ __ ] her and her
husband you know they they had money and
they had time to
sit around and get high and tell stories
and
write books they were they went to the
lord byron's
place on lake geneva yeah
i think they smoked opium a lot i think
they did too yeah a lot of opium they
probably were [ __ ] with weed too
because weed was around
yeah i don't know what they call it the
story was they go to the co they go to
the house
and um the villa diodati is what it's
called that was
which is actually what the game i
designed was called
but um so yeah it was her it was percy
shelley they were not married at the
time but they married later
um lord byron john polidori who was ju
who was a writer but also lord byron's
doctor and then there was also claire
claremont who was
mary shelley's half-sister i think yeah
and she was sleeping with lord byron too
yeah there was all these big [ __ ]
festivals and [ __ ]
pretty much they they were that was a
weird scene in itself they were like
look they were like proto-goth
scene i guess well they were they were
very yeah they were very
um progressive for the time like they
were very you know they were all up in
the literary thing and like um
mary shelley's mom was like a big like
advocate of like women's rights you know
even back in the [ __ ] early
1800s um you know what i mean so there
was a lot of that kind of
stuff and so they go to the house and
then
um they usually would like go outside
they go do
row boats and fishing and [ __ ] like that
but because the weather was so shitty
and
like it rained like all the time like it
was just like these torrential storms
so they were stuck inside so basically
they were
probably allegedly smoking opium they
were reading to each other from this
book called phantasmagoria which was
like german ghost stories
and then lord byron had the idea hey
let's all write a ghost story because we
can't go outside and do anything and say
we're kind of stuck in the house
so they all wrote stuff and mary
shelley's was kind of the only one
that i mean john polidori's the vampire
that was kind of influential because
this was
you know way before dracula but um
mary shelley was the only one that
really made any kind of like last
lasting impression but um but yeah so
like i said if you keep all those things
in mind and like i said if you've seen
any of larry pheasant's other stuff
um i don't think you know anything that
he does in this will be that much of a
surprise to you
um but it is kind of like a slower burn
it's more like a philosophical
kind of like a sad sort of story um
but it is much closer i guess closer to
the spirit of the book
than a lot of the other movie
adaptations of frankenstein have been i
guess is what i want to say
i don't know if they even had me back
yeah they did have weed
i think they called it hemp yeah they
might have called it something
i'd have to look it up but there was
there was uh
i know i know that cowboys smoked it
they got it from mexicans a lot that was
a mexican thing
but it did make its way in into the into
into the union
you know uh from if i remember correctly
they were they were smoking it
you know in the new england area thank
you mango and
during the colonial period if i remember
correctly
this is before the existence of the
united states they were up there smoking
it yeah you know there was no laws
against any of that kind of stuff
yeah they didn't really smoke whatever
they didn't really think to make laws
against it until later
yeah and really if you ask me
the illegal most states illegalized
weed this is back in the early 1900s and
it's because
mexicans were important yeah and they
were exporting it from mexico into the
united states
and it was kind of competing with [ __ ]
like booze and other things
so it didn't have anything to do with
safety yeah they would
they would just ban something to try to
uh keep money from flowing
well it was just kind of like um out of
somebody's pocket into something that's
what i
from what i read that it was just like
all the [ __ ] that came out about
absinthe about it being like a
hallucinogen and stuff like that
was the wine producers yeah like because
they were mad that absence was like
taking a
piece of their pie like over in france
thank him thank you mango also yeah he
uh says talking about the haunted summer
ken russell's gothic
is indeed a very good movie and it is uh
based on that exact thing
it might be on 2b at this moment it's in
my topic box like to
my movie topic box to talk about there
was another one too called haunted
summer that i think might have had
julian sands in it
and maybe natasha richardson i want to
say i can't remember i've seen them both
um i like gothic better just because
it's weirder but uh they're both pretty
good you know yeah colin firth might
have been in honesty yeah but all this
all this drug prohibition stuff it
wasn't it started off
as fake it's still fake they're just
trying to make money off of it
and it was a lot of that [ __ ] was made
by real religious people that are dead
now like my grandmother's generation and
they're still
around and they're trying to make money
off of it from the law enforcement and
the prison angles they made a whole
prison industry on it
which part of the [ __ ] united states
problems they need to break down
prohibition thinking you know there
there isn't a problem with that
there really was never a problem with
any of that the people who take drugs
are going to take them whether they're
illegal or not you're just giving money
to drug cartels
yeah you're making them rich but during
the time that there were times where
weed would be illegal but they were
injecting heroin oh that's legal you can
have that
i know it doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
[Laughter]
yeah it's medicine yeah
[Laughter]
so it and it didn't have anything to do
with safety but that's how they would
sell
the law to the people to get them to
pass it
oh we have to keep it out of the hands
of kids kids weren't taking that [ __ ]
i'm still very entertained by movies
like reefer madness though because it's
like obviously the people that made this
movie have never smoked weed because the
people in that movie are like
not acting anything to do
nothing like that nothing
[Laughter]
it was all for economic reasons that
they did that they didn't want the
competition from other things they the
booze
the booze industry wanted to keep the
money dead into their [ __ ] court
well yeah it's like we want everybody
getting hammered yeah and cocaine was
just
legal for most of the most of america's
history and then out in the open
all the way up into the 80s yeah you
know yeah it was it was it was illegal
in the 80s
but not real illegal you weren't going
to do serious time for it
yeah it wasn't until like the late 80s
where they started to really crack down
on that kind of [ __ ]
they cracked down on that during a crack
epidemic
cracking on which was that was poor
man's cocaine you know
you could one pound of cocaine could
make ten thousand pounds of [ __ ] crap
you can't have the poor having a time
can you
nope and then what's funny is that like
the dea
drug enforcement agency said no don't
crack down on that
it'll it'll it'll run its course and
it'll it'll go away on its own they'll
get
tired of it crack down on it it made it
worse
yeah i mean they just started killing
each other over it and [ __ ] destroyed
lives the way you deal with that [ __ ] is
just drug treatment and
and just you can tolerate it it will go
just like any fads they go in and out of
style yeah
you know and you know you had guys that
were
whole generations of little little
scenes inside of the united states where
it was just heroin junkies
both of them are dead now you know but
they didn't do anything wrong they
didn't do it mostly
didn't do anything to anybody they just
sat around slapped yeah which you know
you know
more people should do that yeah
yeah they weren't really known as being
dangerous or anything
you know um yeah it [ __ ] him up but
you shouldn't [ __ ] with it
yeah making it illegal didn't stop did
not stop people from [ __ ] with it
they're gonna take it whether it's
illegal or not well and then sometimes
making it illegal makes it more
alluring makes it more alluring and then
it makes people kill each other over it
because
i'm not doing this 20 years now [ __ ] you
they start fighting back fighting the
cops
shooting at them and they killing each
other over drug money it's just
[ __ ] stupid real dumb it is and then
the dea advised the senate not to crack
down on any of that [ __ ] that was all
back there
during the 80s yeah and uh they said
just
you should be lenient on it it'll come
and go they were right
instead they did the [ __ ] war on
drugs things and but you know what they
knew it would do that it just made them
a lot of money well yeah that made them
a lot of money big
prison contracts big they got involved
in that you know halliburton
and they got involved with [ __ ] uh
expanding law enforcement
big money in that so it just made a
whole
industry off the misery of others that's
what they did
it's the american way yeah it's
predatory it's a predatory corrupt
system
so yeah we went from mary shelley's
frankenstein to
drugs but you know it's it
it kind of tracks all right so uh i
guess that'll do it for this review
once again i have a movie lined up
to watch this evening so we can review
it tomorrow
so as always thanks everybody for
stopping by and hanging out with us for
a little bit
and we'll see you guys again tomorrow